four million dollars was stolen from
these podcasters and I decided to
investigate I found the man responsible
but before we confront him let's go back
to where it all started when Theo Von a
comedian released this our podcast was
defrauded we were stolen from uh the
company that did it as cast media and
the man that did it is Colin Thompson in
total I've just between talking with
folks there's up to four million dollars
that I know of uh we're in the six
figures I know of podcasts are in the
seven figures now when I saw this I had
same two questions on my mind as you do
one who is Colin Thompson and two
y'all are making six to seven figures
doing podcasts I'm in the wrong line of
work I make like four figures here in
the 10 million dollar Studio barely keep
the lights on okay so I went to do some
research figure out you know how these
people are making all this money and
also how they got robbed and what I
found out was that this company that
stole the four million dollars was a
podcast Network called cast media
podcast Network being a fancy name for
saying they represent podcasts to find
sponsors you know all that stuff you
violently skip with the fast forward 15
second button yeah those guys and cast
media would basically work with them as
a middleman they would take some money
give the podcasters the read and then
give the money of course taking a cut
for themselves now that is simplifying
it a bit and we'll go into the details
more later but what you need to know is
that cast media hadn't been paying their
talent on time and what started as being
late for maybe a month had turned into
seven eight nine months late on paying
until one day cast media and their CEO
Colin Thompson says hey we're probably
gonna go into bankruptcy which means you
get nothing unless you take a special
deal with another podcast Network called
podcast one now who's podcast one well
it's an even bigger Network and they
basically say hey we'll acquire you pay
off what you're owed if you sign a new
deal with new terms with us if you do
you'll get back some of the money you
owed now some of the money you owed over
two years and you'll also get stock in
our company
but what stock well podcast Network
stock a company that wasn't public yet
but as of this video now is and is down
almost 50 percent now if you took that
stock in two years you could sell it how
much it's worth at that point is dubious
Now podcast one would say they were just
trying to help it wasn't their debt so
it's a great deal now the more cynical
view of this is that it's kind of strong
arming creators you either take the deal
or you'll never get what you're paid I
mean podcasters like Jim cornette were
literally told in the event that cast is
unable to close the podcast one asset
sale it will likely declare bankruptcy
so take the deal or lose everything
you're owed and to make things stranger
podcast one was paying cast media in
stock for every podcaster that took the
deal so if you agreed and wanted the
money you were owed you're kind of
bailing out the company that got you
into this mess so obviously some people
didn't like that deal although I'm
understandably others did and took the
deal and look I'm not here to litigate
whether those podcast One deals are good
or bad frankly it's not the point of
this video all cleanups are gonna be
messy what I did want to know though is
how did that four million dollars go
missing in the first place and to try to
find out I began to reach out to
everyone starting with Colin Thompson to
ask for his side of the story you're
being accused of
basically stealing four million dollars
your clients say you defrauded them
what's your side of the story
yeah I appreciate you reaching out you
know
um I wanted to talk with you because I I
appreciate the work that you do um I
appreciate that your journalistic
integrity and I know that you're gonna
tell a fair Story cast is sort of the
dream of of the vision of Independence
you know Free Speech not bound by sort
of corporate Norms
um the ability and the background
backbone to support Visionary talented
unique independent voices people like
Theo Von
um you know cast perspective was
Independence is the product there were
plenty of times where
you know we believed in a show uh he ran
into trouble maybe it was canceled in
one way or another and canceled
quote-unquote and and we stood by our
creators right continue to support them
through that time you know when maybe
more corporate organization wouldn't we
we wedded the storm together
um we believe truly that that's what you
know was unique and special about cast
and my heart and soul is still into that
Vision I'm a musician originally
um and I got into this because I wanted
to support shows that were
bucketing the trend going against the
grain but unique and important to the
broader dialogue
um but where's the where's the four
million I mean I mean yeah I hear you I
hear you every everybody's got a Grand
Vision but the Grand Vision when it you
know when we get to this point everyone
wants to know where the money is not
what the vision is sure you know we
built an infrastructure a cast that I
wasn't in tremendously proud of I
believe that over the years we generated
better revenue for creators
um paid them out more than other
podcasts would necessarily be able to
because we invested heavily in
infrastructure took an individualized
approach anecdotally
um you know we but you're saying we pay
out more but I I mean I mean clearly
that's you know kind of not true right
wait wait but you asked for my story do
you mind if I I just just tell just tell
the story you know we're getting to the
financial difficulties sure sure
um you know uh our vision it really
worked creators benefited made made a
lot more money than than they would have
um uh and many creators are you know do
have more money in their pocket now
because of that however
During the period from February 2022
until February 2023 our unit economics
changed drastically
our Revenue per download which is an
important metric for analyzing sales
performance you know free from content
performance considerations
dropped by 58 percent
in other words over the course of those
12 months the revenue that we could
generate on one download
um moved down by 58 you know okay that
took three minutes to get to a real
answer and I've got to be honest this
whole conversation was about that
painful talking to somebody who owes
creators millions and he's telling you
how he got them paid so much money is a
little frustrating but setting that
aside the central claim of Colin is that
all of this happened because revenues
dropped in 2022 and he just couldn't pay
people on time but as I spoke to people
about Colin I realized late payments
weren't a new thing at all people told
me that was always the case okay you
joined them in 2018
2018 yeah so when did you start getting
late payments
basically like they didn't come when
they said they were going to come and
when did you stop getting full payments
I can answer that right away that was
right before from the first check we
were supposed to get it didn't arrive
when he said it was never on time it
wasn't unusual if it was like a month
late a month and a half late and then
when it goes from all right a month late
to two months late to three months late
and then I would say Hey where's this uh
where's the deposit that go Yep they're
trying to figure out man he says it's he
has whatever investment coming you're
gonna get this huge lumps of money so
then that's didn't come then you're
looking at you know now you look at four
months like it was the money they nearly
got six months like okay man where the
hell is our money yes that's a huge
problem of course up till 2023 money had
slowly started coming in so people were
letting it slide but as these balances
built up over time eventually brynden
and Brian realized they were owed 400
Grand on the fighter and the kid and
upwards of 1.6 million across all their
shows now remember Brian is just
informed about I'll find the kids you
have to manage dick boy golden hours
other shows that are owed money so
Brian's like can you believe this I'm
like yeah that 400 Grand is terrible
no we're right wow 1.6 million what are
we doing here now I should be clear
Colin denies that there are these
payment issues before 2022. your talent
says they stopped getting paid as early
as 2021 and they had issues and delays
well before 2022. no I'm not I'm not
aware of any difficulties
um before you know the end of 2022 the
beginning of 2023 then I talked to his
business partner and everything changed
he told me accounting was always a
nightmare my name is Dustin canaus I was
Colin's business partner as you would
introduce me and the VP of
production and creative development with
gas media one of the things Colin said
is he was not aware of any accounting
issues you know early on
um is that true did you guys hear from
Talent about because I every tell and I
talked to said they were constantly
complaining about accounting
yeah I mean everyone from uh from the
beginning had complained about how long
it took to get paid
um the managers would constantly step in
I think all of his accounting was done
through Google Sheets basically and it
was just him but he would never let me
see everything he wouldn't actually let
me see what was coming in and what was
going out
um and I was like
well you know I kind of need to get a
whole picture and he wouldn't he just
wouldn't share it oh that is a red flag
and it also lines up exactly with what I
heard from a lot of the creators the
accounting was always weird people had
to chase it down and the numbers were a
little screwy it led them to distrust
what they were getting from Colin
[Music]
they owed us plus whatever we think they
still kept going for after that date
plus we don't know truly what the
accounting is because stop the supplying
account maybe at one point earlier in
the year their accountant sent me two
different sets of numbers
on what money I was supposed to get so I
don't trust their accounting I can't
emphasize enough I heard this complaint
over and over not just from Brian last
everyone was worried about the
accounting but a lot of people who spoke
up were just anonymous because they were
afraid of Collins suing them which isn't
surprising because Colin warned Brian
who started talking quote the ensuing
damages if you were to cause this deal
to unravel or within the region of 10
million to 20 million dollars consider
this a serious caution it would lead to
decisive legal action so basically he
was threatening people and people are
scared but I realized that these payment
issues accounting issues they were all
Clues sure but not the whole story to
really understand how it could be that
cast fell apart we need another piece of
the puzzle which is minimum guarantees
remember I told you earlier that I was
simplifying podcast networks so let's go
into the deeper waters the truth is
these deals vary very wildly and some of
the bigger podcasters demand something
called a minimum guarantee where they
aren't just paid a split of ads they're
paid a guaranteed minimum every month
and podcasters love this because it
means they don't have to wait so long to
get paid according to Colin though this
is how he fell behind we had months in
there where our gross profit margins
were you know literally negative prior
to any operating expenses because the
minimum guarantees that made economic
sense when we made the deal were just
completely underwater basically he
overpaid cast made deals to bring people
on in the first place over promised and
then couldn't pay even Colin's former
business partner agreed with this
although he thinks some of the money
went to Colin personally as well we've
got Colin's narrative as his business
partner you look at the situation 4
million missing
the big question on everyone's mind
where did the money go
that the money is gone
gone one is
he built a custom house
he was known for going on big
crazy vacations uh in you know he went
to Hawaii multiple times in 2022 and was
posting about it on social media
um
there's not there's not a question of
was there money in in that sense uh to
be able to buy land
where a lot of celebrities go to to
escape but aside from that the other
thing that he has done is essentially
make constants minimum guarantees to new
talent to try to entice them to join
cast media so saying you know I'll give
you a one-year guaranteed 250 000 500
000 whatever guarantee is that I've
heard that even
um as soon as February of this year he
was offering multi-million dollar
minimum guarantees
so oh at the same time or he claims his
revenues are way down he's offering
multi-million dollar minimum guarantees
for talent
yes
you know his priority is trying to keep
the new Talent Happy for a while
um with essentially his whole goal of
selling casts to make big money
in the end
um but yeah he I would say that honestly
most of the money probably went to the
minimum guarantees of other Talent
uh instead of to the people that it was
supposed to go to wow that might be the
closest thing we have to a coherent
answer on what happened to cast media
Although our story doesn't stop there
because obviously that's a pretty big
accusation that some of the money may
have gone to a house so I decided to
look into that and found that Colin
Thompson indeed bought a 1.7 million
dollar house the same year as his
financial troubles and I also found out
that right about the time he was talking
about declaring bankruptcy he moved that
house into a trust where the trustee was
a Wyoming LLC he set up which from Where
I Stood looked a lot like hiding assets
from a bankruptcy right before a
bankruptcy but when I confronted Colin
about this he said I had things
completely backwards the truth is he was
hiding his property for a totally
different reason a very sympathetic
reason we anonymized our address because
we were getting threats in the last 30
days there was there's been you know I
think you can see yeah I think you can
see though how other people might see it
another way where it looks like you're
trying to Shield it by hiding it from a
personal name into a trust owned by an
LLC I mean I'm just I in a very
favorable Space
by where I live right I I assume you
listen to the Jim cornette episodes
where they specifically call out where I
live we were really really concerned we
were getting threats when I heard this I
was pretty alarmed and I totally
understood his fears so I went to go
ahead and look for the episode where Jim
cornette apparently specifically called
out where he lived but it wasn't there
actually Jim cornette never mentions a
specific address but a general area but
way more damning for Colin's story is
the fact that that episode came out in
July but Colin formed his LLC for moving
the house in June
before these threats ever happened he's
creating this shell company so I found
it very hard to believe I pointed this
out to Colin and he said this quote they
revealed General details and I
anticipated the possibility of this
happening Brian threatened it very
specifically in my original email
exchange with him back in May so I got a
hold of those emails there was no threat
in them instead Brian said things like
consider this a serious caution we're
gonna make sure to endlessly let all
listeners know with great detail that
Colin Thompson a podcast one stole our
money because he doesn't know how to run
a business which is sort of true this
guy doesn't know how to run a business
so I became increasingly convinced maybe
just maybe Colin might be lying to me
about why he hid his house in a trust
with the Wyoming LLC trustee okay I know
this is a bit inside baseball right now
but it's important because I think it
reveals intentions because I then looked
up the website he used to create the LLC
and the website tagline for Collins LLC
is quote asset protection is our only
focus
so you know want to hide your house
wrong company not their focus asset
protection that's your guy I mean I'm
not surprised but I'm surprised that he
tried to say this wasn't the case so I
sent a screenshot of that to Colin
saying hey you're obviously hiding
Assets in this company that specializes
in asset protection planning uh where
the other tagline by the way is
creditors will be forced into a better
settlement or to dismiss the case
altogether and when I sent that to Colin
he responded quote I can't speak to
what's written as marketing material on
a website I didn't write it come on bro
we got you okay I can't go show up at an
asset protection only store and say hey
I was just looking for a little
anonymity you know that's not being
honest and look I don't know how dumb
this guy thinks we are but in my opinion
what happened is pretty simple I think
Colin bought a 1.7 million dollar house
the same year as he had trouble paying
people I think his accounting was always
sketchy I think he over promised people
money to attract new talent and I think
in the end he tried to sell it all to a
bigger company and force these
podcasters into raw deals and worst of
all
this is not a new story Colin is not
unique actually the main reason I took
this case is because we've all seen this
story play out before sleazy business
guy screws over artist or musician or
podcaster look to be honest I wanted to
find out how it happened but I also
wanted to find out how we can learn to
prevent it in the future because to be
honest I'm as much in this media
landscape as these guys and I think the
answer starts with how you get involved
how did Colin find and sign all these
celebs well the truth is some people
were introduced theovan was introduced
by Brendan shop but I asked Brian and
Brendan how they got involved and their
answer struck me as part of the problem
but was he just offering better deals
than everyone else I don't know it's
word of mouth it's because what happens
is they go who is your agency we don't
know the no nobody like we're not
interacting with these people all the
time what happens is it's like if
there's an agency that this person is
with and this person is with you know we
go that do you make money yeah all right
can you hook me up and then especially
when Comics are talking like man this
guy is killing it for us man I made 1.6
million this year like damn that's more
than I made who you you think you would
take me on then it becomes this like
Snowball Effect and you know and then
everybody's there yeah this is the issue
and look it's not to absolve Colin it's
not to put any blame on anyone who got
screwed over here but the truth is
people are always LED around with these
dollar amounts oh you made this much you
know that's how they get you in these
bad contracts and then they don't pay
you and you're left chasing a Wyoming
LLC to nowhere so this isn't just about
these podcasters it's everywhere it's
about 360 deals in music mcns with
YouTubers and just honestly business
people begging you to let them control
your money and then you getting scraps
it's as disgusting as it is common and I
really hope that any aspiring people in
media learn from these mistakes and
scams and realize you don't need these
middleman people most of the time but
more than that do not trust people with
your business who promise you the world
in fact usually that's the worst red
flag oh you're gonna make all the money
just sign here it's a trap and you never
know what's in the fine print until you
read it just ask Dylan danis
foreign
[Music]